Trascrizione: Ilaria Camboni
Revisore: Michelangelo Bardella
Non ho mai osato nella mia vita.
Eppure sono qui, su questo palco,
abbagliato dalle luci.
Da solo, a parlare di solitudine.
Ci tenevo a presentarvi questo ragazzo.
Lui è un hikikomori.
Ma chi è un hikikomori?
Adesso vi spiego tutto.
Un hikikomori è un fenomeno sociale
di origine giapponese,
dove l’individuo tende a distaccarsi
dalla vita sociale, tendendo
a isolarsi e a confinarsi.
Ma questo perché?
È facilissimo capirlo.
Nella società giapponese,
già dall’infanzia
l’individuo è sottoposto
a un eccessivo carico
di responsabilità e stress.
Dalla nascita!
La persona può essere definita
“non eccellente”.
Questa realtà non è presente
solo dall’altra parte del globo.
In Italia sono più di 100.000.
100.000 questi cosiddetti hikikomori.
Queste persone
nel loro mondo si sentono al sicuro,
come a voler sfuggire dalla realtà.
Sfuggendola, infatti, però,
cercano di creare nuovi legami,
a modo loro ovviamente,
attraverso videogiochi, oppure mettendosi
in contatto con l’esterno
attraverso la tecnologia.
Non vi pare un po’ paradossale?
Ho notato che anche noi usiamo il telefono
per restare connessi
gli uni con gli altri.
Ma non ci rendiamo conto
che questo legame è illusorio.
La mancanza di contatto visivo porta
a un’estremizzazione delle emozioni.
Vi faccio un esempio.
Vi è mai capitato di esporvi
su un social network,
ricevendo magari commenti negativi
da chi vi stava vicino?
Magari perché non vi riteneva
omologato alla massa,
oppure semplicemente vi riteneva strano.
E allora ci si ritrova a sentirci soli
anche quando si è circondati
da persone, conoscenti.
Amici.
O famiglia.
In questo periodo,
tra Covid eccetera, mi chiedevo:
“ma questi nove millimetri di schermo
ci stanno davvero avvicinando”?
Oppure ci stanno semplicemente
allontanando senza rendercene conto?
Alzi la mano chi non si è mai sentito solo
almeno per un istante,
durante queste varie quarantene.
Non siate timidi.
Non c’è nessuno?
Qualcuno?
Uno. Due.
Tre. Quattro.
Beh, dai, la minor parte.
Perché la maggior parte
ha avuto questa sensazione.
Aristotele diceva che un animale
come l’uomo non è fatto per stare da solo.
Anzi.
Abbiamo tutti bisogno di qualcuno
che stia al nostro fianco.
Chi trova compagnia nella famiglia,
chi negli amici.
E, per quanto vogliamo stare
un attimo da soli,
è pur sempre un momento,
magari per riparare
la nostra persona dall’interno.
Persino gli eremiti, persone da sole
e isolate su montagne molto alte,
cercano o magari sono già in compagnia
di qualcosa che sia sufficiente per loro,
qualcosa in cui credono.
E allora mi chiedo:
“perché abbiamo paura della solitudine”?
Basterebbe stare vicini
gli uni con gli altri, per esempio.
Perché, ammettiamolo,
nessuno vorrebbe provare
quel vuoto silenzioso e buio.
Vorremmo tutti delle braccia,
perché sono fatte per questo, le braccia.
In avanti, per abbracciarci,
per portare gli altri quasi dentro di noi,
il più vicino possibile.
E allora impariamo ad abbracciare
anche la solitudine.
A stringerla come se fosse
la nostra amica più stretta.
E teniamo bene a mente,
come diceva Balzac,
che, sì,
la solitudine è bella.
Ma abbiamo tutti bisogno
di qualcuno a cui dire
che la solitudine è bella.
Grazie.
(Applausi)